bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 3
février merci de nous rentrer pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal tout
de suite on commence avec les titres de
cette édition édition spéciale pour ce
mercredi 3 février le préfet des
yvelines serge morvan est notre invité
état d'urgence économie fusion
départemental il répondra à nos
questions mettre l'enseignement à
l'heure du numérique c'est le projet de
l'académie de versailles et de la dsd n
78 à l'aide d'un kit des professeurs
deviennent ambassadeurs du numérique
auprès des élèves dans les yvelines de
l'écriture du scénario phase de post
production en passant par le storyboard
tout est expliqué à la galerie de l'écu
de france sur le stop motion lettres de
femmes
une exposition à découvrir jusqu'au 7
février à viroflay et les agents de
police font la grève des pv en cause l'
annonce de la suppression de
l'avancement spécifique ancienneté une
mesure qui permet aux policiers exerçant
dans des secteurs difficiles de
bénéficier au bout de trois ans d'une
bonification d'un 10 selon le syndicat
alliance
les carrières vont donc être ralentis
l'attend pour les mutations province va
se rallonger pour les policiers le
commissariat de versailles de vélizy la
police judiciaire de versailles
la ddsp 78 et la police aux frontières
de saint cyr l'école et de plaisirs sont
d'ores et déjà concernés
les fonctionnaires du commerce du
commissariat de versailles les motards
et la compagnie d'intervention des
yvelines ont déjà annoncé qu'ils
suivaient cette grève des contraventions
et cet après midi un meeting
d'information publique organisée par le
syndicat cgt des cheminots de versailles
a eu lieu à la gare de versailles
chantiers
il met en cause les réformes envisagées
par le gouvernement et dénonce une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail la cgt a également lancé un
appel à la mobilisation et à la grève
jeudi 4 février
cela concerne toute l'île de france un
train sur deux circulera sur les lignes
des rer a et b pour cette réunion deux
invités ont fait le déplacement le
président du syndicat britannique et des
cheminots et son mono son homologue
italien du syndic
usb transports ont parlé de leurs luttes
dans leurs pays respectifs et détail au
micro dé camille lambert
l'idée c'est de mettre en perspective
les situations qui vivent dans leur pays
en termes de privatisation du rail et
des attaques contre les conditions de
travail des travailleurs du rail dans
leur pays
et puis d'un devoir regard de ce qui se
passe et des conséquences parfois
dramatiques notamment en angleterre dans
leur pays
bien qu est-ce qu il risque de nous
arriver et ce contre quoi il va falloir
qu'on se batte voire même qu'on s'unisse
temps cheminots que usagers parce qu'il
en va aussi de l'intérêt des usagers et
ce soir édition spéciale du journal en
compagnie du préfet des yvelines bonsoir
serge morvan merci d'être venus ou de
friedrich il nous a également rejoint
bonsoir bonsoir florane bonsoir et serge
morvan merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau c'est une première de recevoir
un préfet comme ça on va consacrer un
long moment de ce journal a parlé avec
vous de l'actualité de votre parcours
notamment
vous êtes arrivé voici bientôt six mois
dans le département des yvelines c'est
votre premier poste de préfet et on va
débuter avec un sujet forcément
d'actualité c'est la question de l'état
d'urgence françois hollande l'a dit
répété il souhaite une prolongation de
trois mois c'est aujourd'hui que la
mesure a été présenté en conseil des
ministres avec les avant-projets de loi
d'application de la réforme
constitutionnelle également le trois
quarts des français sont favorables
selon les sondages à cette prolongation
de l'état d'urgence il ya aussi eu des
manifestations contre ils font pas
oublier ceux qui s'y opposent
vous en pensez quoi est-ce que c'est
indispensable de prolonger l'état
d'urgence
aujourd'hui je pense qu'effectivement
étant donné l'état de la menace est un
donné l'importance des mesures qui
peuvent être prises dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
considéré qu'il fallait prolonger l'état
d'urgence d'autres moins j'y suis
évidemment pour ma part en tant que
préfet favori concrètement l'état
d'urgence cela signifie aussi une
restriction possible des libertés des
couvre-feux des assignations à résidence
est ce qu'on peut faire un bilan dans le
département des yvelines depuis la
promulgation c'était le 14 novembre
l'ont demandé
des attentats sur paris oui c'est exact
depuis le 14 novembre nous avons procédé
avec les équipes et notamment les forces
de sécurité intérieure police et
gendarmerie que je remercie félicitent
de leur implication dans ces toutes ces
mesures dans toute cette lutte contre la
délinquance et contre le terrorisme nous
avons procédé à 110 perquisition
administrative
le ministre a signé cette assignation à
résidence
de manière plus globale également mais
dans le cadre plus général de la lutte
contre la radicalisation islamique nous
avons par exemple procédé à dix
interdiction de sortie du territoire
pour des adultes et une vingtaine de
propositions de sortie du territoire
pour des mineurs donc c'est vrai que ça
encore en vigueur aujourd'hui à quel
moment ce sera levé ces assignations à
résidence alors qu'elle suit au moment
de la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
toutes ces mesures d'assignation à
résidence sont remises en cause et
renouvelée si nécessaire donc
l'automatique non ce n'est pas une
obligation c'est pas automatique donc ce
n'est pas une obligation de le
renouveler mais le ministre avec
également le ministre l'intérieur
avec évidemment ce que nous nous pouvons
lui dire non au niveau local décidera ou
non de les reconduire ou de les arrêter
alors puisqu'il est question de l'état
d'urgence peut-être quelques mois sur la
prévention de la radicalisation avant
même les attentats c'était aussi une
priorité de l'état depuis 2014 des
listes un numéro vert et un site
internet quel bilan vous faites un peu
justement sur cette question alors les
les personnes signalées dans les
yvelines représente chiffre d'à peu près
300 donc il ya 300 personnes signal nous
devons lutter contre la radicalisation
islamique c'est un travail évidemment de
sécurité c'est ce dont vous venez de
parler perquisition
affaire judiciaire les perquisitions ont
donné par exemple lieu à 19 19 suites
judiciaires
sur les 110 dont je parlais à l'instant
il y en a 19 qui ont donné lieu à des
suites judiciaires
mais c'est aussi la prévention et la
prévention ça veut dire qu'il faut
d'abord détecter
il faut évidemment savoir quelles sont
les personnes qui sont dans cette
démarche se radicalise à sion avec le
risque effectivement de de passer un
autre stade de radicalisation et il faut
prévenir alors prévenir ça veut dire
quoi prévenir la radicalisation c'est
évidemment tout ce qui est du cas scion
tout ce qui est social mais c'est aussi
savoir détecter et donc d'où les
formations à la prévention de la dca
lisation y en a eu 10 de 20 à 30
personnes plutôt 30 personnes récemment
et qui vante d'ailleurs se terminer au
mois de mars et nous avons formé 300
acteurs c'est 300 acteurs donc c'est des
enseignants c'est assistante sociale cds
et lui c'est pour qu'ils puissent
effectivement détectés au changement de
comportement soit d'un jeune soit de
manger d'ailleurs dans les prémisses une
radicalisation qui peut les conduire
je parle aux personnes radicaliser à se
lancer dans des actions qui seraient non
républicaine et contraire évidemment
elle nous fait juste une question aussi
parce qu'une fois qu'ils sont détectés
comment vous intervenez vous des
radicaliser ces personnes ça faisable
parce qu'une fois que ces détecté une
fois qu'on a identifié alors déjà sur
les identifier on peut effectivement
comment on pourrait dire les contenir
d'armes des actions on peut aussi les
suivre pour savoir si effectivement il
ils franchissent ou non la ligne blanche
c'est très important là dessus et puis
évidemment nous essayons aussi de
répondre aux actes qui sont délictueux
justement ces rejets mort massilia des
foyers de radicalisation qui sont
détectés dans les yvelines si oui
lesquelles est ce qu une attention
particulière leur apporter oui mais il
ya effectivement des territoires où il
semblerait que la radicalisation soit
par bouche à oreille à oreille par
influencer les autres plus importante
qu'ailleurs
donc nous savons nous nous savons où
sont ces foyers là nous les lampes dont
j'ai pas tellement envie de stigmatiser
les territoires où les villes mais ça
mais aujourd'hui on est mentionné ça
avait été déjà détecté avant qu'il y ait
aussi ces attentats le travail a déjà
été mené a été fait mais là nous nous
remettons en cause une bonne question
aussi nos modes de travail y compris
police gendarmerie préfecture pourquoi
pas un ne remettant en cause le mode de
travail pour être plus efficace
considérer qu'ils ont des choses à dire
toujours écrire l'histoire moi la chose
aurait fallu et en tout cas il faut
aujourd'hui aussi il faut continuer en
tout cas on peut rappeler aussi que le
procure de versets dont 20 sont les
coûts et annoncé la création février
d'un complot local de traitement de la
délinquance dédié à la lutte contre la
radicalisation en coordination avec le
parquet de chartres la première réunion
doit souvenir d'ailleurs au demain jeudi
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
déjà sur ce sujet ça concerne ça
concerne la le parquet directement et le
parquet a aussi embauché recruter une
assistante qui va travailler
effectivement particulièrement sur ces
thèmes en lien étroit avec nous de notre
côté à la préfecture nous avons aussi du
recrutement de personnes qui vont être
affectés directement et
et spécifiquement au traitement de la
radicalisation
donc nous travaillons en bonne
intelligence avec le procureur 410 cloud
et aussi avec tout le tout les substitut
au procureur adjoint je crois qu'il ya
d'un côté le traitement judiciaire
1 de l'autre le traitement administratif
ce qui est important quand même c'est
que chacun dans son rôle nous
travaillons ensemble a diminué a
évidemment les risques et les
conséquences de cette radicalisation une
dernière question justement autour de
cette question de l'état d'urgence et
puis on va avancer un petit peu dans
l'entretien il ya plusieurs aspects à
l'action du gouvernement sur les
questions d'état d'urgence de
radicalisation il ya aussi l'aspect
sécurité prévention
vous avez lancé une campagne autour des
gestes qui sauvent
au lendemain des attentats savoir réagir
aussi alors il y aura 80 cette session
qui vont être
organisés pendant les week-end de
février pour apprendre les gestes qui
sauvent
c'est essentiellement assuré par le dise
la protection civile et la croix rouge
avec comme partenaires les mêmes plus
les élus pour s'inscrire
le site de la préfecture permet de le
faire aujourd'hui il ya dix 10 personnes
possibles par ces sciences a fait 870
personnes y en a cent quarante-sept
aujourd'hui de personnes inscrites dont
qui est déjà une demande dédiée à une
demande là aussi des sessions qui sont
organisées par l'éducation nationale ou
samedi 6 février on a trois sessions
organisées par l'éducation nationale on
atteint 50 personnes à chacune des
sessions votre sujet présence argent
vous êtes là en place avec nous on va
parler de vous vous êtes énarque vous
avez pris vos fonctions résidait donc en
août dernier comme disait wilfried vous
avez travaillé deux ans donc au
ministère de l'intérieur notamment comme
conseiller technique et dernièrement
vous avez été directeur du cabinet du
secrétaire d'état chargé de la réforme
territoriale vous êtes travailler sur la
loi de décentralisation du 28 janvier
2014 qui vise à clarifier les modes de
scrutin des collectivités des
intercommunalités mais aussi clarifier
leurs fonctions leurs compétences leur
périmètre
votre analyse des yvelines qui est quand
même un département assez hétérogène les
les fonctions que j'ai occupées avant de
devenir préfet des yvelines vous avez
vous n'avez pas cité mais mais je sais
pas me reprocher ce n'est pas un
reproche
j'étais également directeur général des
collectivités locales pendant trois ans
de juillet 2012 à août 2015 donc c'est
pour ça que je le dis évidemment la
direction générale des collectivités
locales et la direction d'administration
centrale chargée de préparer élaborer
les textes de la réforme territoriale
dont le brevet l'intercours et donc
notamment les nouvelles
intercommunalités même s'il n'ya pas que
cela il y avait aussi les nouvelles
régions
on en parle beaucoup il ya eu des
rencontres hier et avant-hier entre le
nouveau président de région est présent
a expliqué le premier ministre pour
parler d'emploi et de développement
économiques donc ça c'est les régions la
région
ab bénéficie depuis le 1er janvier 2016
et surtout depuis le 1er janvier 2017
bénéficiera des compétences premier en
termes de développement économique et
d'emplois et puis il ya les
intercommunalités également donc et au
sein des yvelines j'ai eu le plaisir de
constater que les choses étaient bien
avancées en matière de construction
intercommunale puisque dans le cadre du
schéma régional de coopération
intercommunale un certain nombre
d'intercommunalités de grande taille de
population importante ont été créés au
premier jamais 2007 j'ai signé les
arrêtés en fin d'année le création
notamment par exemple la communauté
urbaine grand paris seine et oise qui
comprend quatre cinq mille habitants on
aurait su département ou ou celle de
saint germain boucles de la seine qui en
comprend trois cent quarante mille
donc je suis ravi moi parce que
l'intercommunalité c'est avant tout une
une un regroupement de communes qui
permet de mener des politiques publiques
plus importantes et plus pertinente en
faveur de la population par le
regroupement des moyens des ressources
et des objectifs politiques des élus qui
est qui composent des communes qui
composent cette intercommunalité donc
attendez intercommunalité forte on peut
faire plus de choses au service de la
population
mais ça s'est fait dans la douleur
quelquefois il ya certaines communes qui
n'était pas très favorable à leur
rapprochement avec l'une ou l'autre des
intercommunalités un exemple puisque
c'est sur le secteur la ville de
coignières l'ancien maire avait même
organisé un référendum et la population
s'était prononcé contre l'intégration
dans saint quentin en yvelines
alors c'est difficile évidemment parce
que certaines communes et je les
comprends
où certains élus ou voir la population a
peur d'être dilués dans un ensemble plus
grand et de perdre finalement la
maîtrise de son propre avenir
je crois que
ça c'est des craintes qu'on a avant
lorsque ça se passe bien deux ans ou
trois ans après les mêmes communes les
mêmes élus ne veulent surtout pas sortir
dans l'intercommunalité parce qu'il se
sent aperçu eux mêmes que ceux qui est
peut être fait au niveau de
l'intercommunalité très favorable pour
eux et donc j'espère que dans quelques
semaines en les quelques années en tout
cas à quoi ni un comme ailleurs ceux qui
ont émis des doutes
ben s'apercevront que au contraire c'est
vraiment une bonne chose
l'intercommunalité c'est pas la réponse
miracle mais c'est une bonne j'ai ça
crée aussi des tensions entre les partis
politiques entre la droite et la gauche
où je veux en venir sur saint quentin en
yvelines s'est passé conflictuel
meilleures relations sur la gestion de
cette agglomération
là aussi pour avoir une intercommunalité
qui fonctionne il faut qu'on trouve une
manière de travailler en commun
quand je dis on sait les élus surtout
une manière de travailler en commun qui
apaise les relations alors il peut y
avoir au moment de la constitution au
1er janvier 2016 certain nombre de
tensions moi je fais confiance aux élus
concernés pour qu'ils trouvent les
moyens de travailler ensemble au service
de la population
parce que c'est l'intérêt de tout le
monde est le leur dans les prochaines
semaines donc je ne suis pas inquiet je
suis par contre très vigilant je regarde
ça de près notre problématique ledit
département c'est aussi l'accueil des
gens du voyage deux aires de grands
passages doivent être créées près de 150
places doit être créée ou on est ce
dossier qui avait déjà commencé avant
votre arrivée
alors y'a 2 quand vous prenez le schéma
départemental d'accueil des gens du
voyage qui a été adoptée en 2013 vous
avez deux aires de grand passage qu'ils
ont été prévues l'une au nord du
département l'autre su ça l'honore a
déjà été identifié et la décision a été
prise maintenant une fois que la
décision est prise il faut la mettre
un oeuvre il faut qu effectivement cet
air fonctionne j'espère que ça sera
possible à l'été prochain pour cela il
ya un certain nombre d'aménagements à
faire c'est à triel-sur-seine vous le
savez tout le monde le sait je crois
mais enfin ceux qui le savent pas je le
dis dans le sud du département nous
n'avons pas encore réussi à déterminer
le lieu exact lorsque je suis arrivé en
août
j'avais dit qu'effectivement je prendrai
la décision puisque c'est une décision
qui relève de l'état de définir le
terrain où les terrains mais en tout cas
le terrain susceptible d'accueillir une
aire de grand passage dans le sud des
yvelines
j'ai dû remettre un peu ma décision que
j'avais prévu de prendre mois de
novembre du fait des événements du 13
novembre qui m'ont conduit à ne pas m
comment pourrais dire une décision
susceptible de créer des divisions au
sein du département alors que nous
avions besoin de deux de l'action de
tous contre les les attentats mais je
reprends je reprends le dossier j'ai pas
oublier ce que je vous ai dit et c'est
important que nous fasse nous fassions
tout ce que nous avons dit donc d'ici la
fin du mois de mars
je prendrai la décision sur les aires de
grand passage du sud des îles vie entre
temps je vais consulter encore donc si
on revient au sujet donc des
intercommunalités donc on marche on
marche des intercommunalités c'est le
département des yvelines qui est amenée
à être bouleversé il va se rapprocher
des hauts-de-seine avant une éventuelle
fusion vendredi sera lancé un
établissement public de coopération
interdépartementale ainsi que la fusion
des sociétés d'économie mixte
d'aménagement alors avant de nous dire
ce que vous en pensez
serge morvan nous avons posé la question
aux yvelinois regardez pas ce sera bien
ça ferait de grands départements qui
pour l'emploi pour l'habitation non très
bien non il faut pas l'intérêt on a déjà
saint quentin en yvelines qui développe
et on va pas se mettre avec la défense
je suis pas contre 1 parce que toutefois
il y avait la seine et oise qui
comprenait éloize et puis les yvelines
alors on a réduit et puis pourquoi pas
si ça peut réduire éventuellement les
frais oui je suis pauvre vous faudrait
certainement rebaptisé le département
comme ça se fait pour les régions mais
il n'y a aucun problème et la réforme
région ça a été du n'importe quoi alors
donc maintenant je me méfie de tous les
avis sont différents votre réaction
ajustements par rapport à leur sens inné
de ses habitants alors en tant que
directeur général des collectivités
locales ou directeur de cabinet du
secrétaire d'état à la réforme
territoriale comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure j'ai travaillé sous l'autorité
du gouvernement pour faciliter les
fusions possibles de département donc je
ne peux pas être contre une fusion de
départements dans le département où j'ai
été nommé préfet donc je suis par
principe favorable après c'est quand
même une question qui concerne les élus
d'abord et leurs populations comme vous
le savez il faut qu'ils aient qu'ils
mettent cela à l'ordre du jour si on va
jusqu'à la fusion de leurs assemblées
départementales et qu'ils obtiennent
trois cinquièmes des voix pour si c'est
le cas après le dossier passer à l'état
et l'état par un décret en conseil
d'état donc doit examiner l'intérêt la
faisabilité du projet de fusion donc on
n'en est pas là encore mais c'est une
première étape que de créer un
établissement public interdépartemental
et de fusionner les cem et même je crois
savoir le service d'archéologie
préventive donc c'est une première étape
je suivrai ça de près d'un référendum ou
pas donc la loi justement de 2010 2015
de janvier 2015 ne rend pas le
référendum obligatoire
maintenant rien n'empêche effectivement
s'ils le souhaitent pas la volonté pour
l'instant de pierre bédier le président
du département 2 mai mais les
les conseillers départementaux
représente la population du département
donc à partir de où ils sont d'accord
c'est au choix des élus et présidents et
des des présidents là en question de
savoir si oui ou non ils veulent faire
un référendum
le département justement la semaine
dernière vous étiez devant les élus de
ce conseil départemental des yvelines
vous avez fait le bilan de votre action
on pourrait parler de la délinquance
avec un bilan plutôt satisfaisant plus
près ce que 28% d'élucidation des
affaires d'atteintes aux biens par
exemple diminution de 17,49 % des
violences physiques
il ya juste deux sujets puisqu'il faut
faire des choix qui ont retenu notre
attention c'est déjà la question du
logement
ensuite on parlera de l'économie avec
floral mais sur le logement l'enjeu
principal c'est de poursuivre la
construction pour plus de mixité sociale
et vous voyez forcément où je veux en
venir c'est cette fameuse loi sru qui
impose des quotas 25 % de logements
sociaux dans les nouvelles constructions
dans les communes
aujourd'hui toutes les communes n'y sont
pas et notamment aussi dans les yvelines
alors il ya eu beaucoup de logements
sociaux qui ont été créées en
en 2015 dans les yvelines c'est même
remarquable parce que l'augmentation de
nombreux logements sociaux dans les
yvelines est à peu près 28 % en 2015
alors que au niveau national on est même
bien loin de ce chiffre au niveau
régional bien loin de ce chiffre ce qui
prouve qu'on peut créer des logements
sociaux dans les yvelines maintenant
force est de constater comme on fait
aussi parfois que les taux requis par la
loi ne sont pas atteints par tous et
donc il va falloir créer en 2016 quatre
mille logements sociaux supplémentaires
si on veut rester dans la trajectoire
que nous impose à tous la loi dite sru
modifié par la loi dite allures d'enfer
et donc ben j'y serai très attentive
avec des services direction
départementale des territoires et des
communes qui nous sommes mal j'ai
aujourd'hui il y a alors qu'ils jouent
pas le jeu
j'irai pas jusque là parce que par
exemple je vous prends mon exemple ya
huit communes aujourd'hui en 2015 qui
sont qui n'ont pas atteint leur objectif
et qui souhaitent partir des carences et
dans le département ou 8 dans le
département 8 et sur ses huit communes
tout on était d'accord pour signer des
conventions quand même le mixité sociale
avec l'état donc elles n'ont pas atteint
leurs objectifs mais on peut pas dire
qu'elles ne jouent pas le jeu
maintenant c'est vrai que année après
année les objectifs sont plus difficiles
à atteindre et que si on ne fait rien il
est possible qu'en 2016 on est une
trentaine de communes dites 40 cédant
qui n'atteignent pas leur objectif
alors qu'il n'a que 8 en 2015 évidemment
il faut les sanctionner ces communes
alors il ya des dispositifs qui sont
prévus et effectivement pour prélever
sur leur budget
des sommes qui sont de plus en plus
croissante au fur et à mesure comme
s'éloigne du moment où on aurait dû
atteindre l'objectif donc c'est parfois
assez lourd et donc je ne doute pas que
nous aurons des discussions
intéressantes avec tous les élus des
maires concernés dans l'année 2016 que
les choses soient faites et vite
voilà on parle d'engagement on parle
aussi à d'économie du soutien à
l'économie justement l'industrie
automobile est un enjeu de taille sur
notre territoire un hub automobile va
être mise en place ce serait un outil
donc facilitateur et structurants qu'est
ce que ça veut dire concrètement pour
les acteurs de la filière
bien ça veut dire concrètement que 1 ce
qui concerne peugeot et renault dans le
val de seine on met en place un
dispositif qui permettra de mettre en
commun non seulement les idées les
débats des uns et des autres mais aussi
des plateformes susceptibles de
faciliter les embauches et les
reclassements et c'est excitant
donc c'est un élément très important
pour l'avenir de la filière automobile
qui comme vous l'avait dit et si
importante pour les yvelines et pour le
val de seine le président a annoncé à
vouloir étendre les compétences des
régions en matière de formation et à
d'apprentissage dont son plan d'emploi
d'urgence le conseil départemental déjà
l'outil ne révèlent une réelle verrez à
une question des primes pour les
apprentis 250 à 500 euros vous allez
aller plus loin vous à les promouvoir
justement à l'apprentissage du côté des
entreprises en tout cas l'apprentissage
est effectivement un vecteur très
important d'emplois et de formation qui
a suivi pendant de trop nombreuses
années une certaine stigmatisation et
que l'on doit aujourd'hui au contraire
promouvoir
donc tout ce qui pourra être fait sera
fait au niveau de la préfecture des
yvelines dans les compétences qui sont
celles de l'état et de l'état
départementale si vous me permettez
cette cette rapidité de présentation les
murs rapidité parce qu'on arrive bientôt
à la fin cette saison thomas justin
danoise à dire mais vous serez le
bienvenu pour revenir parlé sur ce
plateau bien évidemment
juste une dernière question puisque les
départements et qui expriment parfois
est en tout cas en ce moment pas mal de
colère sur les baisses des dotations de
l'état par exemple vous leur dites quoi
de pas s'inquiéter
en tant que représentant de l'état et
non je leur dis qu'effectivement
actuellement il ya des discussions assez
importante entre l'adf l'assemblée des
départements de france et l'état
notamment le premier ministre pour
travailler sur les comment pourrais dire
par exemple sur la recentralisation du
rsa ou sur ce genre de d'action sur les
dépenses département il ya aussi des
économies qui peuvent être faites dans
le cadre de l'action de chacun des
départements cela étant je suis bien
consciente des difficultés budgétaires
des départements aujourd'hui que ça soit
celui des yvelines où d'autres
départements disques expliqué volonté de
rapprochement aussi comme avec les
autres chaînes qui peut-être
effectivement on a expliqué ce faire des
économies merci chargement merci
wilfried merci à serge morvan vous
retrouver leurs portes
le reportage donc sur l'exposition au
stop motion et lettres de femmes tout de
suite avec sephora mamani dont le nouvel
nouveaux lits sion du kiosque que votre
magazine culturel sur saint quentin en
yvelines
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition par l'équipe numéro 6 de mode
d'éducation au revoir au revoir
vous